I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And I'm working on trying
to make the mobile web
platform better for developers
and trying to educate people
on how we think mobile
web development should
be kind of doing, I suppose.
I was going to start
this off by saying
that I think everyone
in California
is a little bit too
cheery, especially because
of the sunny weather
and everything else.
So I decided to bring all
the wet weather with me
from London, just so
everyone kind of experiences
what it feels like to be me.
So I suppose the first
question everyone has,
why mobile web UX at a
developer conference,
and why someone like me is
talking about mobile web UX?
Well, I always used to
have this impression of--
is anyone actually a UX designer
or an interaction designer?
OK, I'll be careful.
I always used to think
UX or interaction design
was for people who wore
turtleneck sweaters and berets.
But it actually
turned out that UX
is critically important
for everything
that we do when we're
building applications.
And if you're a
developer, and you're not
skilled in the arts of
user experience like me,
what do you do?
So it's critically important
as well for the mobile context
because-- I don't need to
tell you guys all about this.
But we know mobile
is big, right?
Unit sales are kind
of skyrocketing.
OK, there's an existing
desktop presence out there.
But every single one of
these devices that gets sold
has a really capable
mobile browser on there.
And if you look at
some of the work
that the Apps team
have been doing
over the past couple
of months, they've
been doing research
on what people
like about mobile, what people
think about mobile websites.
And pretty much everyone likes
a mobile-based experience.
They hate desktop
experiences on the web.
So we know mobile's huge.
And if we're developers, how
do we deal with this context
where we need to define and
build for the mobile web?
Well, if you look at kind of
the way mobile native is going,
they're kind of really
pushing forwards
on what it means to be a native
developer and a native kind
of UX or native experiences.
And they're trying
to push forward
these kind of different
interaction styles.
So we have, obviously,
voice interaction.
That's a big thing
on native platforms
now, whether it's Google Now or
Siri and these types of things.
We also have card-based
interfaces and gestures,
and all these things that
didn't really exist maybe one,
two years ago.
And if you compare
that to the web,
we are actually doing pretty
well on the web at the moment,
in the sense of we
are starting to get
some great mobile-based
experiences out there.
We've got Forecast,
the BBC, Yahoo.
Everyone is building
these kind of-- everyone
who knows and gets
that mobile is
critical is starting to build
mobile-based experiences.
But they don't take
advantage of as much
of the hardware capabilities
and interaction patterns
that native applications
are starting to do.
So my talk was going
to be about how
we could bridge that
gap, how we could start
to use voice
interactions, how we
could start to
use swipe gestures
and card-based interfaces.
But I look at the-- well, the
top 1,000 sites, originally.
And I was trying to assess what
the common patterns are, what
the mobile-ness
of the sites are.
And it was actually
really startling.
We found some really kind
of interesting things
where 53% of sites still
had a desktop experience.
And these are the top
1,000 sites, right?
This is the head of the
mobile web is still desktop.
There's a couple of
really great examples,
Wikipedia and Google,
Yahoo, and a bunch
of others that get mobile.
But everyone else in the
mobile web, it kind of sucks.
They don't actually
seem to think
that the mobile web
is actually important.
And this desktop experience
is actually pretty bad
because, basically, the
way the browser works
is, it goes, well, we know
you've got a desktop web.
The web is for
desktops at the moment.
So we're going to have
to scale everything down
to fit on a mobile device.
And if you look at some of
the stats from Nat's team.
And I'll try and
share a link later on,
where basically
76% of users prefer
optimized mobile experiences.
This was a survey of
1,000 users at the time.
And no one is really
catering for that
at all on the mobile web.
We also found that 25%
of sites, regardless
of whether they were
mobile optimized or not,
their content didn't fit
in the mobile viewport.
And this is an example of
a site where basically you
could scroll around the site.
You couldn't zoom
out from that view.
It was terrible.
You can't zoom out.
You have to pan around
the user interface just
to read some text.
It's not a great
user experience.
And it's quite common
in the top 1,000 sites.
And we found that a whole
bunch of developers--
I think it was actually
65% of users, sorry--
hated the fact that they have
to scroll around the content
to actually find the
piece of information
that they want to
find on the site.
And then we found
that 83% of sites
had hard to touch
areas on the screen.
Now, quite a lot of these sites
were-- just maybe one or two
little buttons were
kind of quite small.
But then you get sites
like Hacker News, which
I know a lot of
people really love,
and I absolutely
love it as well.
But it's completely
not optimized
for the mobile experience.
And then when you actually
try and click a link,
the browser has a
really hard time
trying to figure out what you
actually meant to click on.
This is actually a really hard
problem to solve at the moment,
well, on a desktop
type of experience.
But when you're building
mobile experiences,
it gets a little bit easier.
And this is my
blog from ages ago.
It's horrible.
And as you can see, I'm
not a graphics designer
or an interaction
designer or anything.
But basically, of the top
1,000 sites, 60% of them
had readability issues.
And this actually
comes from the fact
that if you're not
developing a mobile site,
and the site has to get squished
down onto the mobile device,
without zooming in, you have a
real hard time actually reading
the text.
And if you see from
this screen shot,
actually what Chrome
has tried to do
is tried to be clever and
actually boost the font size
as well using the text
auto-size that Greg
talked about earlier on.
And I'm going to kind of briefly
talk about that later on.
But basically, text is not
readable in the mobile web
at the moment, it seems.
And 10% of sites in
the top 1,000 sites
still used plug-ins,
plug-ins that
don't work on the
mobile web, Flash,
Java applets, Silverlight,
Unity 3D, all these things
where we've been building kind
of rich internet applications.
And they've been able to
do some great stuff for us.
But people still
actually have this
deployed on the
modern mobile web.
So actually, this is my
first ever kind of mini
product announcement.
We're trying to
build a tool that
helps you identify and
understand the problems
that you would have
as a web developer.
And this tool is
kind of-- the tool
is kind of focused towards more
of the developers who are not
naturally interaction designers,
just to help you identify all
those issues that we
talked about before.
So I know Bryan mentioned
PageSpeed Insights
a couple of minutes ago,
where it analyzed your network
performance of your site
in the context of mobile.
Well, we're extending
this further today.
And it's in the test
version at the moment.
You're the first guys
to actually see this.
But we're extending
PageSpeed Insights
to also do user
experience analysis.
And we're trying to get
the fundamentals correct.
We're not trying to say,
hey, your navigation
is kind of busted.
Your off-screen menus and
all these types of things
don't work.
We're trying to make
sure you actually
get the fundamentals correct.
And I'm going to go through a
quick demo of this in a minute.
But basically, this tool loads
your site in a mobile context
and then analyzes it to check
for the viewport, the viewpoint
content size, whether the
text is actually readable,
whether the links and buttons
and other areas are clickable.
And it identifies the
uses of legacy plug-ins.
Now, this is very
kind of early stage.
And we really, really,
really want your feedback
on this tool, whether you
think some of the insights
are a little bit too harsh
or critical and other
types of things that you, as
developers, can understand--
features that we could
assess programmatically
by just analyzing the page.
So I'm going to give
you a quick demo.
I will say, if you bump on
ux=1 at the end of PageSpeed
Insights, you'll be able to go
and test this today on your own
sites.
I'm just going to go
and analyze a site which
I know is terrible, and it
fails every single test.
It's actually my site.
So I was actually
looking for sites.
And I was like, I'll try
my old site from 2010.
Yeah, and it failed everything.
It was terrible.
But anyway, as you
can see here, we've
got kind of the mobile side.
This is the rendered view
from a headless WebKit.
It's got all the speed
criteria that Bryan
talked about before to help
you build better mobile network
performance.
But it's also got this whole
area for user experience.
And what it tries to do is say,
hey, we've rendered the page.
We've looked at what
the content looks like.
And we're going to tell
you the areas where
we think you should improve.
And if you've got a
purely desktop experience,
quite often it tells you you
need to improve everything.
But if you've got a
mobile-based experience,
the number of criteria checks
that it kind of fails on
gets a lot smaller.
The first is legible text.
This is kind of cool.
So it basically identifies
every single piece
of text on the web
page-- I'll just
zoom in a little bit-- which
doesn't render clearly,
doesn't meet the minimum,
say, 12-point style font size.
Now, this is kind of cool.
So I've got a whole
load of things.
I used to work for
Switch Media, so that
was the company I
used to work at.
Let's have a look.
"My Dad's Cycling Blog."
OK.
So you can click on a
link, and it highlights it
inside the user
interface exactly where
the identified problem is.
This is really cool
because if you're
trying to find different
areas of the text
on your page which
have got problems,
then you can actually kind of
identify that pretty quickly.
The really nice thing-- and I
think it's there in the API.
But there's an API back end to
this, which you can actually
programmatically run through
your own workflow tools, which
you could then use against your
site, which would analyze UX
problems across your
site automatically.
So it's pretty cool.
We can find all
these different areas
where everything kind of fails.
And because it's a
desktop site, you
can see pretty much everything
is a little bit rubbish.
And it tells you kind
of roughly how tall
it is on the screen
at that time.
So that's legible text.
The other thing
is touch targets.
So we identify all
the areas on the page
where there's
potential for confusion
by the browser or
the user into what
would be clicked, essentially.
So in many cases,
obviously, it's links.
And it's links inside
text, for instance.
But it's also input
elements, form inputs.
Everything that basically
has a click event which
you can listen to,
it will identify,
look at, and inspect to see
whether it's correctly sized.
So as we can see here, the
search box on this page
is too small.
It's actually-- I don't
know whether it was a-- oh.
There we go.
Do it again.
It's actually identified the
fact that it's-- and this is
why it's  at the moment.
So we look at this
radio box, it's
714 micrometers on
a typical device.
I don't know what web
developers go and do with that.
But all we know is
it's really small.
But we've got all
these other areas here
where we're trying to identify
all these potential touch
targets which could
be mis-clicked.
But that's not all.
There's also this area
here at the bottom
which identifies
targets which actually
need additional spacing.
Because the way that
the browsers work is
they try and disambiguate
the clicks in the areas
where the user is
clicking on the page.
And if there are
two elements which
are pretty close or
potentially overlapping,
then that creates the potential
for confusion for users.
And one of the things
that we're doing here
is we're trying to identify
the tap targets which
would potentially be
too close and overlap
and actually provide potentially
the wrong action for the user.
And then some of the basic
things as well, size,
the content for the viewport.
As you can see here, everything
is sized incorrectly.
But what this is
trying to say is--
this is the critical area here--
that the actual physical size
of the page is 1,299 CSS pixels.
And if you've ever done any
mobile web development before,
you'll know that the actual
default size of the browser
is 980 pixels or 960 pixels.
Or no, 980, sorry.
What this basically
means is if the content
busts outside the viewport--
it's too big for the viewport--
rather than scale
it down further,
it forces the user to have to
pan and scroll around the site.
So we're trying to identify
areas where on the page
you've got content
on the page which
will cause the page to bust out
the side of the mobile device,
in theory at least.
And then we have the
configure the viewport.
Now this is a
relatively simple test.
If you haven't got a
viewport, it'll tell you,
you haven't got a viewport.
If you haven't got a viewport,
and then you just drop one
into your site, you're not
going to have a good time.
So you're going to have to
think about actually building
a mobile experience, which
I'm going to try and talk
about for the rest
of this talk now.
So this is PageSpeed Insights.
This is one of the
things that we really
want you to go kind of go
out, play with, give us
a whole bunch of feedback
about whether you think
these checks are
actually good for you,
whether they actually
work on your site as well.
Because we found
instances where there's
bugs for-- tap target
menus across the top
just don't work very well.
But we want as much
feedback as possible.
And if you go to
that page, there's
a feedback link
right at the bottom.
So this talk really is about
mobile web UX building blocks,
getting the basics
right so that we
can build really
compelling experiences
on the top in the
future, whether that's
with Polymer kind
of web components
and a whole load of other stuff.
We want to get to
the point where
you don't have to worry about
everything that the PageSpeed
tool essentially
is checking for.
So I've split this into two
different sections, display
and interactions,
and how they relate
to the kind of
PageSpeed Insights tool.
Display is about how the content
is presented on the device.
And obviously,
interaction is about how
the user manipulates the
screen and manipulates
all the content,
whether it's a sign up
form, whether it's a payment
button and those types
of things.
Because if users can't
interact with your site,
they don't buy things.
They can't log in.
They can't sign up
for your service.
And you have a really
bad time on mobile.
So we look at display.
And I'm going to go through
this pretty quickly.
And I really hate
doing this slide.
But the most important
and critical thing
that you can do for building
a mobile web experience
is make sure that
you use a viewport.
The viewpoint defines
essentially the size
the content should
be on the screen.
And this is all
recommended configuration,
meta name equals
viewport, content width
equals device width.
Because that essentially allows
you to ensure that everything's
sized to whether it's 320
pixels on iPhone up to about 380
on the Nexus 4.
And it basically
means the browser
doesn't have to scale
the content down
from a traditional
desktop experience
into a more mobile experience.
And I think that's a bug
in Chrome at the top.
We'll get from there.
And actually, the
reason why I want
to show why this is
actually kind of critical
is that I've taken the way
that the browser renders
desktop content
on a mobile device
and compared it to
how it's rendered
on a viewport configured page.
And as you see on
the right-- it's
probably a little bit
hard for you guys to see.
But that's a
12-point font, which
means that at arm's
distance, it looks
like a 12-point font
on a page, essentially,
on a normal piece of paper.
If you don't have a
viewport, it roughly
reads like a five-point font.
It looks like the point where
it's nearly kind of unreadable.
OK, we have retina-based
devices which
let us distinguish the layout
of the text a little bit better.
But five points is
really not that readable.
Nexus 5 is the same.
Everything is roughly
a third of the size
of what it's actually
intended to be.
So a 12-point
font, in this case,
reads like four-point fount.
Nexus 7 obviously is
better, bigger screen
and all those type of things.
But it's getting
to the point where
the text on a default
mobile experience
or a desktop experience
on a mobile device
is completely unreadable.
Seven points is just at the
point of being unreadable.
And obviously a Nexus 10 and
kind of the iPads as well,
it's a lot less noticeable.
Not having a viewport,
you get to the point
where the text looks
like a nine-point font.
Kind of what I told you then was
really a lie, because basically
browsers try to
compensate for the fact
that they know that
the desktop web is
terrible on a mobile device.
So in Chrome's case,
we use text auto-size.
And basically what happens
is, just as the page loads,
an algorithm goes through
all the text nodes
and looks to see
what text it should
resize to make it more visible.
And on some pages, like my
blog before, it's not too bad.
The content at the
top of the page
is made bigger because
that's the primary focus.
But then you get
to sites like this,
which is Hacker News, which is
the same page as we saw before.
There's certain comments
which read really well,
like the browser's gone,
yeah, this looks important.
It's not semantic analysis.
It's just kind of
some basic heuristic.
But then there's other
bits, like in the middle
here, which you
can't read the text.
You can't read the text here.
You can't read the
text on the device.
You have to zoom in.
So the algorithm isn't perfect.
And the best way
to get around that
is to start to design for a
mobile web based experience.
Obviously, user
viewport, there are
little hacks to kind of get
around it by making sure you
[INAUDIBLE] over
100,000 pixels high.
It's not even worth going
there, because that's
just one of those things which
might change in the future
when people get rid of that.
But essentially, browsers
try to compensate.
And when the browser
tries to compensate,
it kind of starts to ruin
your design essentially.
It doesn't represent
how you actually
intended the user to
read your content.
And obviously, fit the
content to the viewport.
There's not actually
anything technical
that we can say about this.
It's just make sure
everything is sized correctly,
and there's no kind of
horizontal scrolling.
Vertical scrolling is fine.
And horizontal scrolling is
actually fine by default.
But if you have to have the
user pan in multiple directions,
that's when users actually
start to get frustrated.
And I'll share the link later
on where the Ads team have
done this analysis to actually
show that users don't like it.
But the interesting
thing is that scrolling
varies from platform
to platform.
And iOS, at one point--
I think it probably still
does-- used to
have a scroll lock.
So if you're kind of moving up
in the vertical orientation,
you can't scroll left and
right at the same time,
because it's saying, well,
you don't want to pan around.
You want to just look
at the content itself.
But we want to get away
from this situation
where you have to actually
move around the web like that.
I do have a question.
Who's got a 24-inch phone?
No?
Oh, OK.
That was really
heavy, by the way.
It was crazy.
So I'm not going
to tell everyone
about this too much,
like media queries.
We should be kind
of concentrating
on mobile first design,
responsive design as well.
Obviously, you can
design your site
to work better on
portrait or landscape
and a whole load of other stuff.
This is one of
those areas that's
super critical for
web development.
You want to be looking at how
you actually design your site
to be responsive,
rather than have
to do it all in the server.
It's best to do
it on the client.
I'm not going to go into
it too much, because I'm
pretty sure everyone
knows about this.
The thing I want to
do say is about how
you decide the break
points in your site.
And Paul Lewis has been working
on a redesign for HTML5Rocks,
which is our
documentation resource.
And the old site looks cool.
The new site looks cool.
But what happened is on the
original site on the left,
we basically tried
to size for devices.
So every other week, we would
look at Google Analytics
to understand the
different types of devices
that were available or
accessing our content
and whether it was
a tablet device
or whether it was
a mobile device.
And then we would
say, well, this kind
of looks like a tablet size.
We'll push them to the
tablet user interface.
This looks like a desktop.
We'll push them to
the desktop interface.
And what we found, by rather
than actually concentrating
on the devices, whether it's
iPhone, Android, or whatever
and the device form factors,
we literally just tried
to say that, well,
actually, we'll
scale the content
out left and right.
And we'll decide where the
break points are based off
how the content looks
at that individual time.
So it basically was
saying, you size
the break points to the
content, rather than
the actual devices,
which a lot of people do.
And we were just as guilty of
doing that as everyone else.
The reason why we say this is
because we went from 17 media
queries-- our media queries
for the HTML5Rocks site, if you
go and check it now, is
just an absolute mess.
And it's really
hard to maintain.
And you get into
this weird situation
when it doesn't
actually-- we've got
weird overlapping media queries.
It doesn't actually
know what interface
it's supposed to present
to users at any one time.
So we went from 17
media queries down
to something which is a lot
more manageable for us, four.
And we have nice looking
content on desktop,
mobile, and tablet as well.
One of the other areas that
we're kind of talking about
is font readability.
And I looked at the human
interface guidelines.
And this is the whole
PageSpeed Insights
test, the legibility test.
And the human interface
guidelines from Apple
are really cool
because they say,
if users can't read your
text or the word in your app,
it doesn't matter how
beautiful your typography is.
And this kind of is--
it's ultimately applicable
regardless of whether
you're designing
paper-based content or web-based
content or content inside apps.
And our guidelines and the way
that the PageSpeed Insights
tool works is it
tries to say, you
should be sizing your text to
be readable at arm's distance.
Numerous studies, whether it's
Apple, Microsoft, or Google
as well, 12-point
font is the minimum
that you want to
suggest, which is
roughly one em or roughly
16 pixels in height.
But the interesting
thing as well
is that we're
actually trying to say
that what you should
be doing as well
is consider where the user
actually uses your content.
They might be out in a cab
or walking down the street.
And you want to make
sure that there's
a decent amount of contrast
between the foreground
color and the background
color as well.
We don't actually
analyze that yet,
and we're trying to work out
whether these types of things
are important or not for you
as a mobile web developer when
you're checking your site.
And obviously, things like
maintain decent line heights
so that the text
is readable and you
don't have to get confused
between the lines.
Yeah, so font readability
is kind of critical.
And that's one of
the things that we
look for when we're doing
the PageSpeed Insights tool.
We also want to kind of--
we don't check for this,
but we're trying to get people
to limit the use of web fonts
at the moment, especially
on a mobile device.
Because if the web font doesn't
exist either in the cache
or on the user's device,
then essentially-- especially
on WebKit-based browsers
and Blink-based browsers--
you're left waiting around for
the content to actually appear,
because the font doesn't exist.
So it doesn't actually appear
on the site at the time.
And our guidance at
the moment-- and this
might change once browser
implementations change,
essentially-- is just
to use it for headings.
But critical content,
like the text--
like if it's HTML5 Rocks,
the article body content
would just be a normal
system-wide font essentially.
The interesting thing to
say is Paul Irish had a post
on Google+ talking about
the flash of one style text
essentially, where we're
talking about the different
implementations
between browsers.
So obviously, WebKit
and Blink are kind of
quite consistent because they're
both of the same heritage
where the content
doesn't appear.
Whereas, Firefox is a
little bit different.
I believe the text
appears as a system font,
essentially, until the actual
web font is downloaded.
And we're looking for
your feedback about what
you think is the most important
thing, because we want
to make sure that if we want
to be good web citizens,
and everyone wants
to get this, we
have the same type of
implementation across browsers.
And it might be at some
point that the actual Firefox
implementation is
the preferred one.
But obviously, we need a lot
of feedback from developers.
So go to that post.
Have a look at the
suggestions, and then let
Paul and everyone
else know how you
want to have web fonts
presented to the user.
I'll tweet this
link out because I
know it's not exactly visible.
So that's display.
I want to talk
about interactions,
and I'm going to
be really quick.
Click disambiguation
is really important,
because essentially the
user-- this is Chrome.
When the user clicks on
an area inside Chrome,
and it doesn't know
exactly where the user is,
it presents a magnifying glass.
It's a great
accessibility feature.
The problem is, though, that it
actually presents a challenge
to users because there's an
extra step before they actually
do anything.
So we want you as a developer
to try and get away from that.
And I'm going to roughly
go through the process
for this, how this actual
disambiguation works.
Essentially, the user clicks
on the screen, roughly
a 48 pixel bounding box.
Works out where
the click is, adds
in an area kind of like an
error buffer around the side,
finds all the targets
inside the bounding box,
the potential candidates
for what the user actually
meant to click, scores each
element based on the closeness
to the original touch.
In this case, finds
one that's the closest.
That's the closest element.
And then it basically
compares the scores
across all the rest
of the elements
and then tries to find
the elements where
the distance between
the original touch
is roughly about half the
distance to the closest
element.
It's relatively complex.
The code, if you're interested
in Chrome, is over there.
The simplest answer is just
to use sensible padding.
You're building a site,
just don't be stupid.
Space elements out
pretty quickly,
which leads us on to
this whole idea about,
what are interesting
tap targets?
All the different types of
human interface guidelines
talk about things which aren't
native to the web, points
obviously for fonts.
But dips on Android?
What's a dip?
Microsoft is nine millimeters.
I don't know how that
really applies to the web.
But roughly, if you take one
CSS pixel as standard reference
to be a 96th of an
inch, you can roughly
work out that
everything is around
between 29 and 33
pixels in size.
Our recommendation in the tool
that we're using at the moment
is around 26 pixels but
with a decent amount
of padding We're
recommending eight CSS pixels
or roughly about two
millimeters worth of padding.
And that helps the disambiguator
not have to reselect which--
or kind of basically pop up.
The other interesting
thing around this
as well is that if
you're trying to get data
put into your
system interaction,
you're getting users to sign
up to your app or your site,
you want to have
form inputs that
are easy to read and
easy to enter data.
Labels are the thing.
You should always go for this.
Basically, the reason why
labels are actually important
is because in this case it's
doubling the amount of touch
size that is
available for the user
to actually be able to
focus the input element.
Now obviously, you can style
your site however you want.
But in this case here,
I've got the top element
and the bottom element.
Both are touchable, and both
focus the same input box
as well.
So it's relatively simple.
Obviously, it's up to
you how you actually
decide how it's styled.
But it's one nice little
thing that I quite like.
Who actually likes
waiting in the queue?
I mean, I'm British.
I do.
I love waiting in queues.
This is me trying
to get to Berlin.
I patiently waited in
this queue for three hours
without complaining
at all to anyone.
And then I got to
the front, and I
apologized for
missing my flight.
And it wasn't me who
missed the-- anyway, it's
kind of like waiting
300-millisecond click delay.
The 300-millisecond
click delay is this thing
to help us kind of--
oops, sorry-- get the user
to zoom into the content
for a desktop type display.
Now it slows down interactions.
Everyone knows it's horrible.
We don't really
complain too much.
It'd be great if we could kind
of remove that from the web.
I do have a kind
of question though.
And this is styled off the
Google interview questions,
which we know are great
at hiring candidates.
How much time do
we waste every day
with a 300-millisecond
click delay?
Has anyone got a guess?
Right, I have no idea.
That's what everyone
says when they
get asked these
stupid questions.
I have no idea.
What a stupid question.
But actually, I do
know for Wikipedia.
Wikipedia actually publish
all their mobile traffic.
They get roughly about
3 billion requests a day
on mobile, which is 1,400
requests per second, which
is 423 wasted seconds every
second just on Wikipedia alone,
which roughly equates to one
year wasted every day just
waiting around for
your click to complete.
So it's pretty cool.
Chrome is removing the
300-millisecond click
delay, which is great news.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm going to
talk about what we're
going to do because it's not
going to be for everyone.
And it's great for links.
I don't know whether this
actually came across very well.
It looks like the videos
aren't playing properly.
You click on a link.
You don't have to
wait 300 milliseconds.
But as you saw before,
if it takes 10 seconds
to load your page, the
300-millisecond saving
that you get is not--
you've got bigger fish
to fry essentially if your
network requests are that slow.
But it's great for interactions.
And Jake Archibald
made this video.
On the left is the
300-millisecond click delay.
On the right it's a
zero-millisecond click delay.
Everything just feels
a lot more responsive.
You click on a button or
check box, or in this case
it's a link-- you click anything
that has a click handler,
it happens straight away.
It just feels a lot more
natural and reactive.
So how would you
go about removing
the 300-millisecond click delay?
It's not killed for everything.
The simple answer--
and it relates
to one of the very first
slides, user viewport--
make sure the width
equals device width.
But also size the
content in the viewport.
If we don't have to
pan left and right,
then we've got a really
strong indication of the fact
that the user will not have
to zoom in to the page.
So if we don't have
to zoom in, why
actually do the double
tap to click gesture?
Pinch to zoom will still
work, but double tap to click,
we don't really need.
Or use FastClick.
I know some of the FT
Labs guys are here today.
If you're not on Chrome, you
can use the FastClick library
to kind of get around some of
those interaction problems.
Who loves typing on a phone?
Yeah, good.
Because no one loves
typing on a phone at all.
The goal that we want to
try and get developers to
is just to minimize
the amount of typing
that you have to force
your users through.
Obviously, this
is really simple.
I hate talking about
this slide because it's
been around for years.
It's just, take advantage
of specialized keyboards
on mobile devices.
If it's an email address--
say it's, type email--
you'll get an at sign.
If it's a date or a
number-- so if it's
a telephone number-- say
it's a telephone number,
you get a special dial pad.
If it's a number, you
get a special number pad.
If it's a date, you get a
special date entry button.
Now, it doesn't
speed up the time
to actually complete
the form, but it
does increase the accuracy.
And I did some completely
non-scientific tests,
so I'm obviously a
good authority on this.
And some of the tests that
I did where I asked people
to enter certain kind
of data, basically it
was like 95% accuracy at
the time for the input types
because it was so constrained.
Now, that's completely
unscientific,
so don't go about
quoting that one.
But everyone knows, when they
see the correct input type,
they like it.
Also take advantage
of autocomplete.
The browsers are actually
pretty good at this.
And then if you look
at Stack Overflow,
everyone seems to hate it.
But you want to try and get
your users not entering data
if it's already stored
inside the browser.
And the way you get
autocomplete to work
is to use names for the
field labels that are similar
or that are well
known, essentially.
So if you want to get
the first name, f name.
If you want to get
the surname, l name.
The email address,
obviously name equals email.
Those type of things,
they just help the user.
If it kind of auto starts
autocomplete, you press it.
The form's completed
really quickly.
And it's zero cost
for you as a developer
to actually implement.
The next is requestAutoComplete.
So who's heard of
requestAutoComplete?
A couple of people, really cool.
Basically, the
idea behind this is
to have a programmatic access
to the form autocomplete.
And now this another
video by Jake.
It's a really good video.
Or a demo by Jake.
Essentially, you have an API
which uses an existing form.
You call.
You can basically
go, I want to check
to see if
requestAutoComplete exists.
If it doesn't, you
present the original form
so that people can just go
straight through and enter
the data in.
If it does exist, you can call
a requestAutoComplete, which
pops up the box
that we saw before,
lets the users
select their data,
maybe also if you're in the US,
autocomplete the credit card
with Google Wallet.
And then you can go through
and complete the form
and submit really quickly.
The aim is to really
improve the time
to submission for form data.
If you have to
enter this manually,
it's two minutes
just entering text
to get your shipping
address and billing address
and a whole load of other stuff.
And we want to get
away from that.
So the requestAutoComplete
API is there.
And I'm going to
start wrapping up now.
Our goal is to get
as much feedback
at the moment for this tool.
So please go out and check
the PageSpeed Insights tool.
Put ux=1 at the end, and you'll
get the actual tools available.
And I'd like to thank everyone.
I know I've run
over a little bit.
mobile-ux.appspot.com
is these slides.
html5rocks.com/mobile is our
mobile documentation entry
point.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]